[Musik]
hallo
heute gibt es richtig coole burger wir
werden nämlich halloween burger zu
bereiten
also warum halloween börgermoor sli
immer nur eine torte das geht einfach
nicht bereitet uns cooles herzhaftes zu
also habe ich mir gedacht warum nicht
schwarzenberger basis backen und dann
einen burger zu bereiten
da haben wir zu sturm morath kurzweg
hören aber der bürger ist vegetarisch
heute machen wir nämlich grillkäse
wright was richtig lecker schmeckt und
vor allem kann ich dir einfach in der
pfanne braten und das ganze wirklich
super schnell und einfach zubereiten
ich finde die kombination aus
schwarzenberger band weißen krise und
den roten der rote beete einfach richtig
genial
also ich super langsam entspannt ich
gehe mal so lang wie zufällig wie steht
mal rüber und wo mir kurz raus und
kühlschrank und damit ich mal gespannt
wir haben ihm das problem hast dieses
problems kommt immer bei uns einer zu
besuch der immer immer weh getan ich
immer kommt immer und aber auch für
nicht vegetarier für mich zum beispiel
ich jetzt auch mal gerne fleisch aber
ich liebe vor allem den grillkäse der
schmeckt wirklich super und man kann
halt echt coole sachen machen auch so
kleine spieße und so weiter und ich hab
mal gedacht warum denn nicht einen
daraus zubereiten
zuerst einmal werden mit dem bürgerbus
zu bereiten dann nehme ich mein ganz
normales basic rezept wert allerdings
noch ein bisschen farbe zu fügen und
hier vorne seht ihr schon mal die
zutaten für den hefeteig brauche ich
einen würfel hefe 200 millimeter warmes
wasser 30 gramm zucker 30 gramm honig
etwas schwarze lebensmittel verpasste
260 gramm butter milch zweier vier
teelöffel salz 160 gramm flüssige butter
und ein kilo mehl zu erste sich jetzt
die hefe im wasser auf und füge den
zucker den honig und ein bisschen
lebensmittel verpasst ebenso
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich schon mal eine richtig
schöne schwarze farbe und eignen sich
auch lebensmittel verpassten am besten
weil sie eben selten sie sind jetzt
kommen noch die übrigen zutaten also
butter milch eier salz mehl und butter
meter zog ich fühle mich gerade wie so
eine hexe in der hexen werkstatt mit dem
zaubertrank
jetzt kann ich die zutaten verkneten
entweder nimmt jetzt die hände oder ihr
nehmt einfach eine küchenmaschine und
kneten teig wirklich für etwa sieben bis
zehn minuten gut durch falls ihr die
hände nehmen empfehle ich euch
handschuhe aber auch wenn ihr keine habt
gegen farbe auf jeden fall super wieder
von den händen weg
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig fertig ist es ein
schöner weicher geschmeidiger teig ein
bisschen mehl habe ich noch zugefügt
kommt einfach darauf an wie viel farbe
verwendet und auch wie groß die eier
wand also da teig so schön geschmeidig
und weich sein aber eben nicht mehr
kleben also momentan sieht das ganze
noch ein bisschen abgefahren aus aber
später einmal richtig coole berger bands
ich zu euch den teig zu einer kugel
dafür wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr so viel
mehr
und jetzt kann ich die schüssel nochmal
fetten mit der das wachstum spray oder
oder zum beispiel butter legt die kugel
hinein und väter auch die oberfläche
damit sie nicht trocknet und kann jetzt
in teig abdecken und für eine stunde
ruhen lassen ihr müsst doch immer so
gerne den blick hinter die kulissen hier
habt ihr einen blick hinter die kulissen
der murat stars heute morgen hier und
hat geschrieben am laptop und der
teigwaren neben ihm und er sollte im
prinzip auf dem teil aufpassen und er
hat allen entschluss nicht gemerkt dass
der teig übergelaufen ist
murat morax
ich glaube ihnen einfach wieder zurück
und jetzt kommen wir unsere bagger bahn
[Musik]
den gut aufgegangen teig portioniert ich
jetzt sind 80 gramm schwere teiglinge
und die form ich dann mit den händen so
richtig schönen glatten kugeln
[Musik]
die teig kugeln die lege ich dann auch
meine blech und drückte mit der hand so
ein bisschen flach
die brötchen sind jetzt gut aufgegangen
jetzt verrät hier ein eigelb mit etwas
wasser bestreikt sie damit und streuen
und etwas drüber
[Musik]
und so kommen sie jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze etwa 15 bis 17 minuten und
nach dem backen werden sie direkt mit
flüssiger butter bestrichen also an der
farbe erkennt man natürlich nicht wenn
sie fertig sind aber an der unterseite
als ihr müsst ihr dann hoch nehmen und
wenn sie sich gut lösen
dann sind wir fertig
[Musik]
die bürgerbahn sind jetzt fertig sind
auch schon abgekühlt und sehen richtig
gut aus ich freue mich schon richtig auf
den burger jetzt werde ich noch die
restlichen zutaten vorbereiten ich mache
jetzt eine selbstgemachte soße natürlich
eine hamburger soße und ich werde noch
ein bisschen rote beete und käse mit
rein geben
ich sage ich hier vor noch mal die
zutaten für die hamburger soße frisch
ein eigelb 100 milliliter rapsöl oder
olivenöl den saft von einer halben
zitrone einem halben teelöffel salz
jeweils einen teelöffel senf und
tomatenmark eine prise zucker einen
teelöffel tabasco etwas pfeffer für die
rote beete brauche ich ein bisschen
kümmel da habe ich jetzt einen
kreuzkümmel viertel teelöffel eine rote
beete drei esslöffel olivenöl und eine
orange zuerst nehme ich jetzt das eigene
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen tabasco dazu
ihr könnt auch gerne ein bisschen
weniger nehmen da was kocht eine richtig
schöne und so ein bisschen säuerliche
schärfe da noch der halbe zitronensaft
und ihr könnt im prinzip auch schon salz
zucker senf und tomatenmark dazugeben
und jetzt das eigelb erstmal cremig
rühren und dafür verwende ich jetzt ganz
frische eier das heißt sie habe ich erst
heute gekauft und ansonsten hat man halt
immer ein rohes ei in mayonnaise mit
dabei aber ich mache die mayonnaise
lieber selber als dass ich sie kaufe von
daher nimmt einfach ganz frische eier
und schmeckt wirklich super lecker
und jetzt gebe ich in einem ganz dünnen
strahl das öl mit dazu so dass sich die
zutaten einfach gut verbinden
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
pfeffer rein und verrühren das ganze und
schmeckt einfach nochmal die soße ab ob
genug zitronensaft drin ist und tabasco
und salz und da kann ich die soße schon
mal in den kühlschrank stellen und in
der zeit die rote beete vorbereiten für
die rote beete nehmt ihr euch am besten
einmal handschuhe denn ansonsten sind
eure finger ganz schnell mal pink was
natürlich nicht schlimm ist aber die
gehen eben nicht so steht die farbe geht
eben nicht so schnell wieder raus jetzt
kann ich die kurz schälen mit der schale
kann man übrigens ganz toll eier färben
oder auch nudeln zum beispiel und jetzt
werde ich aus der rote beete spiralen
schneiden ihr könnt aber zum beispiel
auch einfach eine küche 03 benehmen und
das einfach treiben
ich finde spiralen jetzt einfach
superschön und vor allem passen sie
wirklich perfekt zu halloween
ich nehme jetzt einfach dafür sollen
spiral fix da geht es nämlich wirklich
super da kann ich die rote beete
einspannen und direkt in die pfanne
geben so cool später im fall david ist
so genial aus sein
da kommt jetzt aus öl mit dazu und jetzt
kann ich die rote beete in der pfanne
anbraten und werdet ihr dann gleich mit
dem orangensaft abschmecken und das
schmeckt wirklich super lecker und sieht
einfach später in unserem
schwarzenberger richtig gut aus
nehmen wir mal so das kann ja dann kann
ich nämlich die spirale zu zeigen
wie lange wir rote leibchen
wenn die rote beete dann etwas 23
minuten angebraten erst könnt ihr den
orangensaft zu geben und dann lasse ich
den einfach verkochen das fest wird es
solange noch weitere bücher verkauft ist
da kommt noch ein bisschen kreuzkümmel
rein und etwas salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
jetzt geht es weiter mit den zwiebeln
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal zwei
zwiebeln geschält hier habe ich etwa 50
gramm mehl und natürlich die wichtigste
zutat der grillkäse denn ohne grillkäse
wäre es natürlich keinen bedburger ich
habe jetzt hier den gaza-krieg außerdem
gibt es einmal in natur in kräuter und
chili und ich werde jetzt gleich einfach
alle drei benutzen und murat darf
sondern einfach probieren wenn ja immer
am besten schmeckt schon jetzt aber
zuerst noch mit der zwiebel an die könnt
ihr jetzt entweder in feine ringe
schneiden oder eben auch in spiralen
[Musik]
jetzt die zwiebeln mit dem mehl
vermischen
so werden sie einfach ein bisschen
knuspriger und ihr seht auch hier
richtig kohle langer zwiebeln kann man
schön streaming ist gleich machen an den
bläschen hier im frittierfett seht ihr
dass es schon heiß genug ist das heißt
ich kann die zwiebel und schon
frittieren
jetzt nehme ich einfach immer so einen
lässt vollgas ins heiße frittierfett und
dann müsste einfach aufpassen dass sie
nicht zu viel rein gibt damit das pferd
eben nicht so schnell abkühlt und dann
überschäumt und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal diese pfanne erhitzen für
den käse die pfanne fertig ist einfach
mit etwas faktoren spray ich brauch
nämlich nur ganz wenig fett und sobald
sie heiß ist kann ich den grillkäse
darin anbraten
den können die entweder in der pfanne
anbraten oder auch zucker draußen auf
dem grill schmeckt beides wirklich sehr
lecker
[Musik]
da kriegen wir dann einfach in die
pfanne gelegt und von beiden seiten etwa
drei bis vier minuten angebraten
[Musik]
jetzt ganz ans anrichten gehen zuerst
einmal schneide ich den bürgerball was
ich bin ja mal gespannt
col da kommt jetzt ein bisschen von
meiner so vertraut das ist momentan so
richtig so ihm so alles lag das muss
nicht sagen ihr müsst ihn würde den ball
nicht einfärben
die haben als halt alle mieter über
lustig aus wenn ich auch jetzt der käse
den schneide ich noch quadratisches
können wir auch vorher machen cool ist
übrigens auch wie kommen auch richtig
cool köln also wenn wir zum beispiel
vegetarische freunde haben wie im sommer
kommen mit grillen dann auch noch einmal
klar manchmal im winter ja wie ich hier
nicht nur so mag dann habe ich natürlich
10 salate unten vergessen
aber dann kommt er eben oben drauf da
nicola jetzt also ein bisschen weniger
hatte mich nicht so rote beete fertig
werden keine rote medien finden muss
morgen aber es ist wirklich super lecker
und ich finde einfach die kombination
aus als ob wir jetzt gespannt also intro
sagt ich bin ich sagt will ich die
wahrheit
okay das ist cool das gefällt mir das
leben
ok erwarte dann mache ich aber drunter
normalen lexus was ihr so sein
ich habe meine mario selber gemacht
tabasco das macht wahrscheinlich auch
kein mensch selber mayonnaise aber das
geht ja super schnell hat man ja gesehen
und ich sag lieber immer also ich sage
mal lieber mache ich die mayonnaise
selber mit frischen eiern als die
mayonnaise zu kaufen mit bodenhaltung 1
und jetzt 8 und man hört auch okay
ich habe gesehen wie ich gesehen dass
einige nur jeder vierte selber kocht
wirklich jeder führt kein schulfrei 34
das stimmt genau ok
morath wir waren gespannt also ganz
ehrlich ich glaube dass der erste
vegetarische burger
wahrscheinlich weiß nicht vielleicht hab
ich schon mal ein versehen aber wenn es
jemand vegetarisch ernährt wird es auch
ganz ganz toll und so sieht er auch aus
weil hier so ein bisschen halloween
mäßig richtig toll und jetzt ruhig
richtig gespannt ich auch sagen eine
auch schon öfter was gegessen was
vegetarisch war aber er dachte es wäre
fleisch drin
er weiß es nicht und wo finde ich die
soße käse roter beete das ist aber
keiner darauf kommen dass vegetarische
meint der schmeckt richtig lecker echte
ja und das sagen soll es nicht nur sei
jetzt bin ich zum spaß braucht er nach
wanzen ja mal der hammer
zehn bands hier sieht eigentlich
verschimmelt ausgespart lukas wirklich
aber es riecht lecker erholt sich dort
wie da werden begeistert sein zimmer ist
möglich ich glaube es kommt halt auf so
einem buffet richtig gut also egal ob
halloween oder nicht ich bin die
schwarzenberger ganz einfach richtig
wohl und es ist einfach so hamburger
verbindet jeder mit fleisch ich find's
einfach auch mal kohle vegetarische
variante zu machen und wenn es dem moma
schmeckt aromatisch
dann schmeckt natürlich liebe ich an den
durch nichts zu tun geschmack kann man
wirklich nicht zu viel besser sagt dann
schmeckt wirklich sehr gut probiert auf
jeden fall mal aus vor allem ich mache
jetzt glaube ich so ein bisschen auf die
rote beete seite rüber gekommen kann ist
ein roter beete ist lecker geht so
appetitlich aus ich werde jetzt gleich
die restlichen bürger für uns alle hier
zu bereiten und dann werden wir ein
richtig cooles buffet hermachen
da zeigen wir euch auch gleich ein paar
bilder und ich wünsche euch schon mal
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen das
rezept findet ihr auf zdf.de und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
ich mache das nicht gesagt ich habe ich
gedacht ich muss wie immer aber diesmal
stand das freut mich morath ich glaube
ich noch zum vegetarier erklären wir
wahlweise mit 33 ja ja nein fällt alles
mit
ich mache mir noch mal neu
[Musik]
[Applaus]